I think india ability and the power
degrees of the definition of superpower
i think the world has changed definitely
the global appearances of revenues
moving east but still they also have a
paper to grade at the country you are
talking about concealed but definitely
campus out of the blood stage with their
voice more development process and
really it has big potential to do and i
think they will approach send after
china whether we can have one superpower
i doubt i think we're gonna have almost
always more than one part of the world
recovering maybe they're efficient in
the other part of the world and at the
end of the day they are all interrelated
we do not set work to have the state
with a decision problem even India what
your kitchen table and therefore I think
we have a global economy everybody else
and dependent on others but there will
be more than one superpower in the
filter and I've already started